sports are an interesting way for people
to experience a collective identity
sport teams in this country have their
own sort of tribal impulses against each
other but then you know drop a few bombs
on Pearl Harbor and then all of a sudden
were one country facing an enemy and and
and you know people doesn't naturally
cohere into groups and when you create a
group just by necessity you're also
creating a whole bunch of people who
aren't in your group and that just
mathematically no that's just a
mathematical truth and one of the
interesting things about the the
Olympics is that it's a chance for
nations to demonstrate their nation as'
to demonstrate the fact that they
actually see themselves as a nation
which is a beautiful thing I mean that
that's what we we have organized
ourselves into Nations that's the modern
world and when you see that on display
can be really moving but it also because
hopefully we're sort of bigger than
ourselves it also allows nations to
entertain some kind of communalism
between each other that sort of
channeled to the nobility of competition
in you and at the end of the day when
you have different nations competing in
the Olympics one of the things they're
all agreeing on is the the incredible
beauty and nobility of the human animal
performing at its absolute peak I'm
reminded of a world-class long-distance
runner that I'm friends with who
competed in the mile in the 1960s and
70s and he was at a international track
meet in England and he was lined up on
the track with the best milers in the
world including the great steve-o vet
and right before they started the race
steve-o vet pumped his fist in the air
his amazing athlete who I think had the
world record for
while in the mile it's amazing athlete
raised his hand pumped his fist in the
air in the air and he said okay
gentlemen let's make it a good one and
what he was saying there I mean he was
gonna try as hard as he could to win
that race but what he was also saying is
look it's up to all of us to bring
nobility to what we're doing and what
everyone in this arena has gathered to
watch so let's do it don't let him down
and I think the Olympics that they're
best can rise to that standard that
Steve ovett said at that moment